hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel in
today's video what I'm going be talking
about is breakouts but you know it this
is a an orderflow channel is based off
of order flow so you know it's not going
to be your traditional um volume
breakout or or range breakout it's going
to deal with Delta breakouts and you
know a breakout is an important event in
trading you know in the markets because
it often signifies a potentially
significant move in the market all right
so um you know before I begin you know
be sure to subscribe to to the channel
if you haven't already and hit that
notification Bell so you know every time
I post up a new video you'll get a
notification and and you can come watch
it and you know if you got any questions
be sure to leave them down there in the
comment section all right so Delta right
in order flow Delta is the net
difference between aggressive buying and
aggressive selling taking place at a
price level right and you're going to
measure it uh you could measure it you
know at an individual price level um one
of the easiest ways to use it is look at
it in a bar by bar basis okay so you
know for those of you just really quick
that don't uh understand what Delta is
right see at the bottom of your chart
there's a numbers um you get positive
numbers negative numbers um bar is
either going to have positive Delta or
negative Delta and just really quick
what is Delta so you know in the two-way
auction right in
the uh markets right you have a bid and
you have an offer okay when an
aggressive seller sells into the bid
that registers as minus1 Delta why it's
because you have an aggressive seller
removing liquidity from the market is
removing
one if you have positive Delta of one
that means an aggressive Trader bought
one contract at the market they bought
it at the offer from a passive seller so
negative Delta means aggressive selling
positive Delta
means aggressive buying okay so again
you know every bar is going to have a
Delta and it's either going to be
positive or negative and on rare
occasions it does happen that it just
ends up at zero you know where it's just
evenly match aggressive buying and
aggressive selling now it's not the
amount
of buying taking place on the offer or
the amount of um volume taking place on
the bid it is the difference right
because you see in a bar right there's
volume that trades both on the bid
there's volume trades on the offer the
difference in this case minus 80 in this
bar is there was 80 more contracts sold
into the bid than bought from the offer
okay in the previous bar it's minus 167
okay so there's 167 more contracts sold
into the bid than bought from the offer
you can see over here there's a one
right there's a three in this case you
know in this bar right up
here this green candle there was only
one more contract bought from the offer
than was sold into the bid again it's
not that there was one Vol contract you
know a volume of one there was 161
traded in this bar but rather the
difference between the aggressive buying
and the aggressive selling was just one
contract okay there was one more
aggressive buying than aggressive
selling all right so when you're talking
about Delta again you know every bar is
going to have a Delta it's either going
be positive or negative or in the rare
instances lands on zero and again you
know when it lands on zero I don't read
anything into it it's just a coincidence
you know if there was one more trade
took place it could be positive it could
be negative right it just you know if
it's zero it's zero just as if it's one
it's one if it's three it's three now if
it is a smaller number I tend to treat
them as neutral because especially on a
Time based chart this is a gold 302
chart um if it you know is you know
within a certain range positive or
negative I just sort of treat it as
neutral and what do I mean by neutral
well it could go either way again
depending on the type of chart so if
there was just one more Split Second in
the you know bar formation another trade
could have taken place and it could have
been you know instead of one it could
have been minus5 okay but when numbers
Delta numbers in my opinion matter the
most is when they are growing right when
they're strong either positive or
negative again I don't put too much
importance in one or three or four but
you know hey M 89 tells me something -
24 tells me something - 167 - 80 -12 you
know it's telling me there's there's
strong selling right when you have
obviously a one a three a four it's kind
of neutral it doesn't really have much
impact on the market because buyers and
sellers are pretty evenly matched in
that bar but then when I see a bar you
know minus 89 it's telling me obviously
there strong aggressive sellers taking
place - 167 - 80 - 112 now
Delta right it's sort of a offshoot of
volume okay now it's obviously it's not
volume itself it's the difference in
volume between the aggressive trading
taking place on the bid and the offer
and we know that with volume right
increases in volume indicate increased
participation and interest from Traders
um in the market right higher volume
reflects higher liquidity and greater
conviction behind price movements okay
so let's take a step further I'll put
your thinking cap
on when you see volume increase right we
know that there's increased
participation right increased interest
now if you see increased Delta either
positive or negative what do you think
that means well it means if if volume
increases right that means increased
participation in
interest Now Delta which is an offshoot
of volume again it's the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sells when it in increases in a certain
direction either positive or negative it
indicates increased
participation to that side either
aggressive selling or aggressive buying
so for example right right before this
Market sort of puked out right you see
the Deltas are kind of small Min - one
nothing 5 6 7 - 11 - 11 1 3 and then
Wham it gets slammed minus 89 what's
that telling you you know Market is just
sort of trading you know evenly matched
here going sideways and then aggressive
sellers are taking over right minus 89
see here minus 24 okay it's not the
biggest number minus 24 but still you
know it's bigger than obviously minus
11s and single digits and then when get
slammed again minus 167 so in this bar
minus 89 in this bar minus 167 you know
aggressive sellers are active Okay and
another clue would be are there selling
imbalances here you got one but here you
got 1 2 3 4 5 right usually when you
have strong negative Delta you're going
to get a lot of selling imbalances if
you got strong positive Delta you're
going to get a lot of buying imbalances
so if you weren't convinced here right
on this Market there just sort of you
know trading normally then Wham this was
your first clue - 89 in the Delta then
again sort of quiets down again four
minus 24 then gets slammed again here
with minus 167 you should be aware that
hey you know what there's aggressive
sellers coming into this Market the next
thing you know Market drops basically
from you know
2405 which is up here but you know 2404
and A2 all the way down to 24 even so
it's a $45 move like within this is a 30
second chart so that's within one minute
two two and a half minutes okay and when
you're looking at Delta right sometimes
you know you're looking at order flow
there's a lot of numbers you got numbers
in the footprint you got ratios um you
know you got volume Delta Max Min Delta
accum of Delta um you know Delta volume
you got a lot of numbers to look at and
sometimes it gets a bit overwhelming I
admit um you know even me as a Trader
sometimes you know there there's just so
much going on and markets moving you
know you need tools that will help you
see things quickly at a glance and one
of the new tools on the order flows
Trader 7 right our newest version of
order flows is the Delta breakout okay
and it's right here now default I
believe is set to uh two 100 but I have
it I lowered it because this is a 302
gold chart and what you're going to be
looking for it's very
simple okay you just enable it right you
can see up
here this is a little bit off the screen
um I clicked apply I enabled clicked
apply click okay what do I see I see
right here this is a Delta
breakout it's gone from obviously you
know small Delta of 4 to- 24- 167 Delta
is breaking out strongly so if I know
that I have strong aggressives in this
case it's a negative Delta breakout
because Delta is increasing to the
negative side and that's why the box is
colored red and you got this little pink
Zone up here that I know there's strong
aggressive sellers taking place and as a
Trader I could focus on okay which way
do I think the market is going I know I
got strong aggressive selling you know I
could cue myself up to get ready to get
short right just as if let's see if
there's a bullish one in here somewhere
here's another bearish one right it goes
from 16 to 12 -2 to -124 but what's the
difference between this bar and this bar
okay and I always talk about this right
let the market take you in just because
Delta increases over you know several
bars here doesn't mean it's an automatic
short if the low of this bar is you know
then the next Bar opens up and we're
trading 2405 and a half doesn't mean you
automatically get short you know you're
trading a breakout or breakdown so what
you
need is this Market start breaking down
so you have your breakout here but the
next bar doesn't go anywhere right it
goes inside of this basically of these
two bars and then goes higher whereas
here here's your breakout right I reason
we put a box around this so that I know
that at the low of this bar right the
second bar the low of this box that's
the area where if we start trading below
it I want to get short okay so that's
telling you below
460 you know basically 460 or 450 and
Below that's where you want to be
getting short and sell off you know look
for the sell off right here it doesn't
break that level so you don't doesn't
break
390 okay so it doesn't trade 380 or or
370 or below so you're not getting
short okay here here's your breakdown
right it's just sort of going sideways
you know 8 - 48 - 5 -1 46 then - 5 - 113
in Delta so Delta is increasing you got
aggressive sellers coming to the party
after the sideways activity the low of
this box since it's a red box is 980 so
where you want to be getting short 970
or 960 that area just wait for the
market to start trading there you just
drop you know this box is going to draw
here you just drop a stop here right
below the low of this box at 60 or or
950 let the market take you in and it
again it drops from you know 950 all the
way down to
06 okay let's take a look at some other
ones there's any more this morning this
is gold
today okay well let's go back to
yesterday see if there's any bullish
ones
okay here's a couple bullish ones this
one okay so it's a big increase right
you see strong selling coming in - 140
-77 this minus5 whatever- 82 then 48
159 then the market goes sideways here
does pop up a little bit but it doesn't
go above this blue box here at 490 is
the high so it doesn't hit 05 so you
would not be looking to get long okay
here's another one okay now here right
this blue box so you know it's bullish
right I see the this little blue Zone
here as well to give me another clue so
I know that if we can trade above 530
which is the high that I'd want to get
long it trades you know 540 550 pulls
back a bit goes sideways for quite a
while you know and starts shooting up
and again you know this is understanding
the markets right if you're getting long
and it just goes sideways on you for 10
minutes or well 10 bars or eight bars or
five bars you know that's a sign that
the trade's not working out you know I
wish every single trade would work out
beautifully but you know sometimes it
doesn't here's a nice bearish one two
bars right your
red box okay next bar goes inside it
doesn't break down until the second bar
right and you can decide you know how
many bars you want to wait I like to
wait two bars rather than just
immediately one bar you I like to give
it at least a chance to make its move
and it does here on the second bar and
then boom the rug gets pulled and drops
you know basically from almost 08 that's
what 780 and the next bar down to below
6 you know 580 and eventually goes down
to two and a half but really you know
getting out somewhere in here is decent
quick nice little scalp so you know that
is the Delta breakout tool on order
flows um Trader and again you know
depending on the market that you're
trading you know you will want to adjust
the Delta threshold obviously if you
know say you're trading a bond um you
know like bonds or 10 years or five
years you're going to want to adjust it
to take into account the the amount of
volume that goes to the market if you
know the default is set to 200 which is
fine for like e- minis um
Mees even some of the Euro currencies if
I was on a one minute gold chart or 1
minute crude chart um you know I'd start
looking at the default setting of 200
but again you could uh sort of go
through your markets and make the
adjustments as necessary all right
everyone so thanks for watching this
video and I'll catch you on the next
video byebye